Stanley Cups are either pink or red for
Valentine's Day and that's probably why
guys want them I don't even follow this
story or care about these cups but it's
pretty obvious from watching one short
clip I'm sorry you think that guys are
buying Valentine's Day gifts in January
get out of here in the history of
Valentine's Day there has never been a
Valentine's Day per gift purchased by a
man for a woman on January 3rd it is it
is it's never happened in fact I'll say
this no man in history has ever
purchased a Valentine's Day gift before
February 11th I've had a few February
12ths where I where I went and I
purchased the gift and I'm feel I'm like
wow I am I'm the greatest husband ever
that I actually I can it's two days
ahead of time and I'm out here buying a
gift already but buying a Valentine's
Day gift for your wife a month early is
the gayest thing you could do not that
there's anything wrong with it